okay well for people who are watching
this live stream this is another episode
of our internal design reviews of the
next version of language and we're doing
several today the first one here is
about system models and integrating
systems engineering functionality into a
language so without further ado where
are we starting
you can open the guide page system
modeling overview okay where do we want
to start today right so where we left
off this thing here right that's not not
not helpful in this scenario this is
part of this is a model part of the
introductory kind so how do I get a real
model here so he can write instead of
hello world you could write component
based stopped electric circuits basis
thoughts electric circuits so you know
yes
you
you
it's kinda hard to tell what that thing
is the small versions are and why did it
pink for a moment there did you see a
pink for a moment no I didn't make it
over over so something is wrong here so
when it got a spinning disc then it
pinked for a moment then it finally gave
the results okay oh this is kind of a
list I mean it's kind of weird that this
has no symbolism that it's a system
model at all
we're not wrapping system model around
it we could but we haven't so far I mean
the symbolism we have is the color of
the border when you select it let's say
that's pretty subtle I mean yeah that
that's supposed to be a system model is
really obscure it looks like some kind
of flag of some yeah I think that the
perspective changed so the problem we
had when we used this I think it's great
to get this big diagrams but the problem
with those big diagrams is that they
they just when you scale them down
they're usually too detailed okay this
is a very very simple diagram no I
understand I understand but I'm just
suggesting that we need some kind of
indicator either an icon of some kind or
or just the wrapping of system model
around the whole thing right don't they
will be terrible right I mean this is
modeled after the graphs way of doing
things but it's not because the graph
way of doing things doesn't have an icon
eyes view right that's true right so I
think you either have to wrap system
model around it I mean doesn't the thing
have a name yes it does have a name no
but I mean the name may be kind of long
and globulus it is often long and
populous okay but but we need another
solution so maybe just wrapping system
model around it there's a decent
solution what do you guys think of that
yeah I think worked I think particularly
since we have this small one now it's
it's probably decent
yeah
okay so if I say system model plot of
percent - what will happen here it will
take the plot the preferred stored again
we're dealing with those weird the weird
Progress monitors but we'll fix that
that's really nice
okay how do I tell where sign voltage
one is if you hover over the components
it's a tells you I can hunt it yes I
didn't succeed in hunting here
I was signed voltage one dot I and maybe
that's it I don't know right so that's
the current inside design voltage okay
but but the fact that I have to hunt is
a little weird is there any way that we
can make that easier I mean you can list
the components how do I do that
the it's a property of the object as a
person - of
right so components is one of the
properties that is very weird what are
those things now those are Ian's in
themselves models crashed right oh no
not that much I've seen that particular
crash before but I haven't been able to
turn it on yet okay all right but but so
those those things so that's interesting
because this whole question about how
how I can eyes things should be I mean
maybe we need something which is more
graphical rather than the word system
model what we system model gets kind of
long yeah well right so let's figure it
out I mean that's a good case so let me
let me just replace that particular
thing so this was system model of or was
it component based dot electric circuit
component based electric circuit
okay so it's these things anyway you you
have specific agenda items so let's make
sure we get to those but I think we my
suggestion would be that we have some
more obvious you know I don't know that
we can use a gear type motif like the
system model thing down here or
something maybe you know we got that
plus sign up there but I don't know what
we can do maybe we can embossed the
thing maybe we should see where the
Jeremy is around um can can somebody go
find go see if Jeremy is here yes
thanks um okay sure we go for the agenda
items maybe yes although I'd like to see
that can I see that particular thing so
if I say percent components here okay it
looked like that I don't know what that
sign voltage so each one of those when
they have those things that look like
want to be u.s. flags what what um it
means they don't have a diagram view
with graphical components so it's
fallback default visualization basically
okay what's the one that's white I have
three three components placed out in the
corners of the diagram view so you get
the small grey dots there okay alright
let's let's go to the agenda right so
where we ended up the last meeting was
how we should how much of the
information of the model should be
present in the full form and typeset
form of system model yep and well what's
there today is yes it's basically the
name so it's basically a pointer to one
to two the state out of core basically
you know in practice it's a state in the
system of the kernel but beware but I
mean if you send this to somebody else
do they have the same thing yeah well in
this case they do because it's a
built-in library right
so they should have you you IDs or
something so that at least it even knows
where it's pointing right yes unique the
name is unique globally to it so if
somebody else on the other side of the
universe
kind of makes up a model they will get a
name that is uniquely defined how does
know if well they they can make their
own that's called the same thing as here
that's true okay but I mean so I don't
understand I mean ultimately this should
probably use the resource system to
store these things no no no well how do
you know that the resource system is
better for storing ready-made examples
for example but this we need some way to
represent one particular system model or
component model that doesn't that's not
a standalone it has dependencies on
other things and it's also not
necessarily useful to look at an
isolation fine but then it's got to have
tentacles which you know are you you IDs
and things I'm not sure we need a UID
for all cases well why not have it
because otherwise you're gonna have
something pointing off to some thing
that you know this is look this this
needs to be some kind of UI
URI that people can definitively find so
there's somebody's named it something
they will not be confused and you know
it'll simply crash right it's probably
if somebody points it into something
would they have they have happened to
have a colliding name but it does
something different right that'll work
yes but I mean that's the same thing if
you have for example files that are
called the same thing yes but they're
local files or the incidents are local
market but okay they only live on your
computer so we're going back to a world
like the world of local files which
mostly we've gotten away from now I mean
you can still deploy this to something
you can
in the future you'll be able to deploy
this - for example well hold on Steven
okay - two kinds of scenarios here which
is important and it just does introduce
something that we have to some extent
but not as much in the system what which
means that you have persistent state
that lives outside of the the running
kernel you know and it's in a different
kernel effectively and we will
independently of that have something
that's globally universally unique you
know so we're sharing with lab rating so
you need this you know this is a thing
you know there's some advantages it is
the state that you have here is exactly
the same state as there the more
advanced GUI sees in fact both of them
can manipulate the same thing and that's
an important that's the problem of them
why is this happening an 11-3 maybe it's
only in the prototype build here I think
Jeremy joined and we had a question for
him yeah okay so this is an icon for a
system model but it is completely
unclear what it is it's even more
unclear when it's this faux American
flag thingy maybe I can give some
background so you system model is a
typeset object that represents a model
one model in the universal models and
for typesetting purposes there are two
versions of that idea we have a diagram
which is the case you see up top with
the gray boxes in that case we try to
reduce the diagram into where each
component basically becomes a little
gray box so this is the large version
and you give me a more complicated
diagram as an example I copy paste one
of these or will it just crash you
should be able to copy-paste us but
those are washable
ah well it might well hopefully not
right okay why did that not get on any
kind of icon view and also why does it
have a blue background so it didn't get
an icon view because there are no
sensible components to this it's
basically more equation based it's not
built out of other components it's built
it's built so far as this view is an
iconic version of whatever you get when
you press it shouldn't it have had
something visible there oh I mean you
could argue that but this one what
happens if we just took the bitmap of
this yeah I don't know why you wouldn't
just render that even if it's not
immediately some delayed kind of
rendering of that icon
no still you look at something more okay
so that doesn't look that great because
that would have to know and this is
really quite simple the diagram in
djenne what is the operation what is the
image processing operation was it
erosion or dilation
anybody remember yeah like that
I mean what could imagine doing
something like that maybe it's crazy
that on its own is not going to work
they're not worse than what we have
especially in the weird flag case yeah I
mean the weird flag case is a custom
this is we don't have anything to render
we can list like that that one now ever
we want that's just something I threw
together but let's see if I can yeah
send me a more sophisticated example but
I'd like to point out this is the way
that external session objects work with
you you IDs right what's that it's I
mean there is I don't think there's that
much similarity except for the I don't
think so hider okay well fine but we
need to address this okay so this is not
that great whatever this gray thing is
that's a huge number of components yeah
well let's see what it is so what's
happening right now is it loading stuff
from the system model of kernel yes okay
all right so in a different model of
things that's just pickup is that is
that can I make get this is an image how
would I get this is a graphic you that's
a property of the model what's called
diagram so percent six brackets diagram
yeah
why does it take so long well because
there are many components basically and
there's a ton of information in the in
that graphic so let me just let me just
see for the hell of it let me just
understand what's actually here so
you
okay what is this by the way
a low-pass filter of the cour rare
variant okay by the way the fun is the
minus ones are really funky there which
ones but minus signs there and it looks
like it's a font what font is that
anyway oh that's a good question
I don't Jeremy do you have any comments
on that front it looks like a crazy font
to me but I can't tell through this
session but it just looks fairly
standard sans I don't think it's a it's
a weird choice it just looks like
standard Arial or something no but no
well these aerial all these icons have
been rear-ended by us yes yes it's a
pity that they still look very
rough-hewn I mean they still look like
they were drawn on some you know
old-fashioned you know pen plotter thing
but maybe that's just the way these
things have to look yeah I think that's
what do you expect and the engineering I
mean that's what the usual diagram looks
like in engineering
thank you free I do so this would be a
quite lovely icon for that thing
wouldn't it hello I mean it just gets it
just becomes noise at some point well it
doesn't completely I mean it's clear
that's a somewhat complicated circuit I
mean you know if we take a clue from the
graphs business right in the graphs
business we make the size of the overall
picture be somewhat dependent on the
size of the graph right not really I
mean that's a recent idea what happened
there that's this thing yes sir okay
there is some more information in the
diagram case yeah but why did it turn
itself sideways is that what you would
expect it's not sideways it's the same
way around
okay or what do you mean sideways the
label third language yes the components
are rotated to make it make the
connection lines nice and not that I
mean it's not something that bothers you
or is that something which you would
expect this is something I would expect
okay all right so look we've got two
issues on the table here one is what the
icons should look like and two is and
now when you generate this icon I mean
clearly the full rendering and getting
everything from them from the system
model kernel is a slow process yes if
you keep a cache of something I don't
know it's down what the flow is here we
partially do that already if we didn't
it would be even slower okay but so that
cache could contain a thumbnail or not
if the minimized one year we have today
the gray one that is actually a bitmap
it's already cached for okay fine
alright it just isn't a particularly
beautiful one okay so the choice of what
we so you have derived that gray thing
from this right yes from this diagram so
in particular if I go back here this is
somewhat funky was it not going back
oh it's some okay that's somewhat funky
ghostly gray thing is some kind of you
know isn't basically an icon of that
yeah it's hard to tell but it's there
right right so
they're couple of issues here one is how
to derive the icon from this right
so you basically need an algorithm that
taken given the graphics will derive an
icon from it preferably quickly okay
well let's take like number three here
what is the diagram form of that thing
whoops what am I doing here line three
yeah line three was just uh Oh with this
thing here yeah that's not an input okay
so that thing there diagram of that
thing there right yeah I think that's
gonna give you exactly what you have
there yeah okay fine okay but so then
this thing here also has to have an icon
derived from it right and that's because
that that part doesn't actually have any
graphical components except the
connectors at the sides it has a diagram
form which is fine so that gives us raw
material to derive an icon all right but
just to be clear let's just try
something here if we say table of let's
say random graph you know let's say n n
n goes from you know four to 40
expected I expected these to get a bit
bigger though the other thing is the be
a little and I yelled for these diagrams
are a bit more complicated in graph
layouts because they have to take sizes
into account where is the graph out in a
graph layout algorithms do not decide
but I'm asking the question if we were
going to make an icon for these can we
make an icon whose size is proportional
that say to the square root of the
number of components sure I mean does
that make some sense or is that you know
would that give us can we can we make
something look messy I said nice you
have more than one in the list it's just
gonna look different sizes together yeah
I think yeah would be nice
even if it's hard to tell I think just
being able to see quickly that they're
distinct from each other and be able to
recognize a unique one that that's
enough even if it's not beautiful yeah I
mean that's that's the point of the icon
okay so we we have we simply have to
figure out how do we derive from the
diagram a reasonable icon right and the
concern is that I mean can you give me
an even more complicated case this
doesn't look that complicated in the
space of all such things can you give me
a more complicated one I mean it is one
of the more complicated ones and it gets
more complicated domain not an
electrical domain so we see some other
kind of iconography or let me find one
what happens then Stephen is that you go
hierarchical you want to limit it the
complexity right and what is that how
does that work in these diagrams do you
get to click them or not no no you do in
system model it in the in the physical
system yes yes yes
and how do we represent that that
unclick ability here if you go that's
the components or the components
property yeah there is one way to get
out two components so for example this
op thing this amplifier whatever it is
is that something which has a drill down
in ends in official system model that
would have a drill down is that true yes
I mean every thumbs up as a
so here if I just look at that it would
be this what just happened here
[Music]
great big long list of
opponents okay it's not that long a list
so if I take these up okay yeah this is
a really uninformative thing right yeah
under what circumstances each one of
these things has a name true yes that's
the left-hand side of each so c7s the
name or is that it didn't aim but what
would happen if we had the end of this
thing right dot dot dot capacitor
written in here doc doc doc capacitance
dot dot dot resistor I guess it would
have to be bigger
well yes slightly it would have to be a
slightly different shape right yeah but
having that last name okay so it seems
like the the last name here which is
kind of like the file name not the
directory is the thing we said dot ideal
op-amp 3-pin yeah right we ever we have
heard that in earlier iterations but
it's often I mean
it's long so so it's gonna have to be a
different shape I mean to do this this
would have to be I mean it might not be
as tall but it has to be if we're going
to put in the name the name seems highly
useful to me yes that the picture of the
components useful to it is but the name
is also useful because of its you know
ground capacitance just right so let's
see if we can't figure out something
which is more of an ordinary flag shape
that has both the name in it and a
diagram so the question of the diagram
did you did you send me something which
is a a non electrical case yes I sent
you
mechanical case that's not that big
that's okay I just want to see what kind
of structure shows up in it
you
okay
by the way I hope you let somebody know
about this is yet another progress
indicator and by the way by telling you
at pinks every time but yes how I said
no I've seen it
like one or two times so yeah
okay so let's take a look at the sky why
is this taken
you
these ones and as far as you asked about
sort of redesign of icons these ones
have a more distinct upgrade then the
electrical ones the electrical ones a
little cleaner but these we upgraded
these yes yes they do look a lot better
than they did before yes somebody from
our
live-streamed suggests why not have the
name be the default and the image be a
tooltip right I mean we could have just
an eye muster typeset and some books
some way but it's gonna be more boring
to look at yeah I mean I like having
these icons here but I you know we just
got to find a way if it's an icon like
this so is there a standard shape for
these things or is that in other words
in the way that these are built are they
because these these two at least well is
there a standard shape or is there not a
standard shape there it's not under
shape everyone is following but it's all
the tools I've seen are basically
influenced you to make this shape like
you're lying down paper okay
it's up to you to change it if those
turn your thoughts on okay so first
question is how do we get let's say it's
that size but it has a name underneath
and it's a dot dot dot blah for the name
and if the name gets too long we can
always cut it off or we could have the
things you know widen to the appropriate
name I don't think it will look that bad
if the things are of uniform height I
don't think it will look that terrible
to have them at different widths Jeremy
your thoughts
yeah Heights more important but you're
thinking wider to fit the the longer
words yes okay but I'm suggesting that
it's just the you know the last word
here and it might look like dot dot dot
dot spring damper system
no long I can check that we might have
to a light even that word in some case
by the way is there a name is there a an
english-language name or is it all these
camelcase things it's all camelcase
things okay about way except where's I'm
weird edge cases but yeah pretty much
okay but we don't have they don't have
so when we they get linguistics and
entities and things we will have to have
actual names for them at that time
that won't be panel taste right but that
has not yet been done is that correct
now we have a prototype entity store for
this well what do they look like in the
entity store then does it say spring
space damper space system
no no currently they have the same
nameless I see is he here okay so
because I mean typically in an entity
store right I mean if you look at
something like I don't know you know
Los Angeles or something right the so
the full name dere is three names right
or something like that well this
particular one right it'll be um yeah
it'll be camels and that particular one
it's it's three names but that's not the
important thing but the important point
is those are camel case but yet there is
a if I say common name of this it will
be like that okay and what's displayed
here is the common name makes sense
right so the like long is this 45
characters okay well that's life um I
mean we could elide them if we have to
but I think I think you should just
render it okay but the question is when
it becomes an entity how is that going
to work maybe you can actually try that
oh let me see oh yeah access that yeah
so if you type entity system model
Esther type name or what it's called
system model yes and the second argument
one of the model names so like this
thing here yes
you know try this for a while yeah okay
it still works
yeah well that isn't really right
because among other things it should
have this kind of indicator that says
system model after it I think it gets
started in some scenarios I don't really
know 100 maybe this is the out yeah
you're right you're right you're right
if I made this input it probably would
yes all right
oh that's wrong it should have a space
there right okay
yup you're right hmm okay it's not the
most beautiful thing in the world this
this name but I get what it is okay fine
so what's the relationship between that
so of that entity then tonight does it
work I mean if I say diagram is that
that's works so there's all this a meant
that the properties are still system all
has properties okay okay okay so okay
back again to the question of how we
make these icons Jeremy your thoughts
here I mean would it help if there was a
color other than white as the background
would it help if you thicken the lines
up I think what you did with the erosion
was good mostly it's just going to be an
image resizing with an erosion and you
know what to figure out how to get the
type in there
not sure if it's resizing based on
string length or or what yeah I can do
experiment okay well so in this
particular case if we take that thing I
wonder if what can we just say image of
that thing
arrest her eyes by me or maybe image
works as well in there should work out
you might want to figure Henri sighs no
but no notice that when we did image
there it pixelated it in a fairly nice
way I mean
we could certainly do erosion on this if
it starts as a graphics just the
graphics resizing will do some of that
for you depending on the you know the
box size now I mean does the erosion
look messy there doesn't look that
what's that it doesn't look very I don't
think it was needed here like if you
were that with a bigger box one more
thing is that this this when you
question query the for the diagram you
actually get all the labels for the
grower way to go everything without the
labels yes it's not document that though
I think if you if you go for a diagram
and then wrap a list around it after
inside the list after the diagram so
person fourteen packets diagram bracket
list diagram comma the string text goes
to fall so I think and everything you
know that's it I hope yes okay alright
so Joe
our position is make this small right
whatever size it should be and then
right now maybe this is nicer if you
keep the colors I could give you some
yeah definitely the colors
I mean it won't be as uniform but maybe
it will be easier to identify it
it looks just fine there's no problem
with that yeah I don't think you need
the frame
you know we'd put the text in below it
and then probably frame the group so
that's easy to get rid of right you want
you want to mark up or you put in yeah I
can I can send something okay all right
let's get back to other stuff let us
know when you have something here okay
so the next issue is this whole question
about how do we serialize this right and
I'm still why so the issue is within the
session this is all gonna work
hunky-dory yes yeah outside of this
session you're kind of toast not true
yes outside of the session you have to
store your estate somehow by using
export for example okay but what will
actually happen if I open this notebook
will I get pinkness and so on Oh what no
no you as soon as you try to use one of
the models it's gonna tell you the model
does not exist but but that it depends I
mean if you build up the model in the
notebook then then you have it how do I
store what what where's the various
models stored in the notebook none of
these are stored in the notebook they
just say model of whatever yes so I
don't understand that you're saying if
the components are universal and I build
the model in the notebook but there's
nothing like store this whole model in
my notebook right no what is that model
there's a bunch of my delicate code
behind that model is that correct yes
that's one part of it and there might
also be external files that are needed
to drive it the simple case it's just a
model like a code basically okay so so
the packaging of the thing is what
ultimately I mean it's a bunch of files
in a file system in a directory
somewhere yes okay I mean versions of
that either
Oh fine which is your model like a code
or we have a way to package model up
with all its dependencies in an archive
so you get a say
we'll file with all its dependencies
okay good French why were you saying oh
that can't be part of the resource
system I mean what could be part of the
reasoner system is one of these packaged
up with all dependencies things yes yes
and I mean if that was the case then
what we could do in principle here is
people could refer to that and you know
it could be other local object with a
UUID or a cloud object with the UID or
something on the resources certainly we
we I think you can already export one of
these to file and I think that's just
gonna work seamlessly with cloud objects
because it uses okay then why is this
thing not some kind of UUID because you
either have access to that UUID or you
don't and if you don't then you discover
that you don't as opposed to having some
random name that you might
coincidentally happen to have I mean a
knight name is not random it's hand
curated no I understand that but it's I
could make up another thing with the
same name yes right so my point is if it
was a you you if somewhere underneath
this doesn't have to be you know like
you have right now the second argument
of system model just seems to be rather
peculiarly true what is the true mean it
means I verified that the model existed
and I can eigen types that it's it's
basically to differentiate it from this
constructor syntax okay but but why not
have that second argument be a UUID that
is the location of that model in in the
space that this user knows about well in
this this in this in the space this user
knows about the name is always gonna be
a unique in itself by definition okay
yes it's not needed okay when I say
create system model
so this one has two four
the name or he don't give it the name if
you don't give it the name then you get
a UID that's the name
so how do I get something with a UUID
yeah that's the default form if you
don't give it a name for example the
first one here will give you a model
with UID that's the name
shake yeah I that is not a standard
format UUID it can't be because it has
to conform to the model like a language
standard but it's not a UUID it's not
being placed that that's the name of a
model in your you know weird Metallica
fight file space but it's not a name
that would be understood in our file
system what what look look look look the
problem is okay what you're doing you
you have something which is in it lives
in memory it there's never final
save it how do you save it next port
that's the only way to save it
yes export of ammo file or export of
this by the way I assume that we're
gonna tag this whole set of
functionality in this version as
experimental right if that's what we
want we can do that I think we should
because I think some of these names and
things may end up changing as we get
more experience and understand how to
get this to run in the cloud so okay so
you're saying if I do an export string
for example if I take this and I say
export string that thing in model
archive format is that right mo you know
I'm not sure your version is new enough
you can't right yeah right okay now
that's that's a look okay okay but you
should be able to do export to the
actual file
okay well I could try that I mean a good
experiment I'll print if you want see it
do that then file print so you can see I
know I know I know I know so I can say
temporary file how do I get a temporary
file I can just do file open I think
create file right without arguments I
think that gives here right I doesn't
have an mo ending
I don't think that's gonna work yes well
maybe create file has a way of giving
you giving an ending that would be a
sensible thing yeah creates a file
current working directory I hate that
well alright okay let's go ah sigh
alright well this cleaned up afterwards
okay so where would you like me to do
this percent 25 comma test
M oh is that right away around you are
right
you
you need to actually specify the mo
that's not fully integrated yet
you
okay lovely yes I know you gave it a
name by exporting it to a name files and
now he knows the model is quote supposed
to be called dust according to
specification over the language okay
okay all right so did we go through all
of these functions here I think we
touched on most of them I think the
major one we haven't looked at this that
much is actually system model itself so
we haven't gone through the properties
for that one and we haven't gone through
how we modify models how do you modify
models there are two ways here wrap
system model around it and then the
second argument is a an association
member that's what you were asking for
Steven yeah by the way we should make
module Icarus spell check would should I
send that okay um okay go ahead right so
what if I a model you type system model
and the first argument this year old
model of the way that you want to modify
and the second argument is an
association of which contains what the
same property you want to modify
okay for example you can modify the
description property with the
Association description goes to the new
string you want them so so this is
system model is nested twice so this is
system model of so in a minute that
thing which was true in one case you're
now making B so if I take this random
system model up here for example this
thing has emit
the second argument to this by the way
by the way by the way by the way by the
way does this auto size in I mean if
that was an image it would auto size
down when it's inserted like that
there's a way of setting it to do that
it's yes
um its image size multiplier you know we
had work I don't know where you got
disabled okay alright okay
but anyway so then here there is some
kind of Association where you can give
something give me an example description
goes to lady kept will be another string
whatever you want the description do be
snow its typing like a like a snail why
is it typing like a snail any idea might
be zoom interfering you know so what
this is the MU the immutable way of
changing it so now if you look at input
form of the result you got you got a new
one of these anonymous on my unnamed new
ID things funky right so the system
model where if I said that diagram I
would get back that same diagram because
the description change is not going to
affect the diagram yes correct
but if you ask for the percent 34 by
description you gonna get your new
description mm-hmm so that's the
immutable way of modifying it and then
we have a mutable way similar to the
open to append duality ouch okay how
does that work so that's a new function
called set system model which we haven't
talked about before you know this is it
now with yes
it's on model creation there's still a
lot more stuff here that we have not
gone over what is this weird shortly on
that one it takes data from Wolfram
language and creates a system model that
basically a single generator in a system
model so you can connect it to other
stuff in your model so it takes like
times here
it's the analog hmm so it's like so a
lot of models see then you need to kind
of they have tables of data they have
other things associated with them and
this is a way to create the bridge from
Wolfram language into these models no I
understand it's highly sensible I mean
but this thing is I mean the thing that
comes out of this is like an
interpolating function of some kind but
it happens to be something you can feed
into a system model right I mean it it
is itself a system model that you can
use as a component when you build new
ones right but for example if I had an
interpolating function or some machine
learning you know predictor function
could I feed that into a create data
system model an interpolating function
yes the other one not yet okay
does it say that Oh
doesn't actually say then too that you
can do an interpolating function here oh
well maybe okay maybe it doesn't say
explicitly says it at the bottom but
yeah so yeah that's more obvious so if I
do create data system model of let's say
range of range of 20 squared okay
much this is the mother couldn't it show
me the actual data no this is a diagram
view of the general components for a new
standard but so now how would I how
would I use this component you can just
feed it either simulate it but then you
get your data back or you can use it in
connected system model components with
other stuff what if I connect two of
them together right you can't connect
two of these together because this one
has an output so you need something with
an input for example a gain or something
okay but if I say system model plot of
line 37 done that will tell you it needs
to know what to plot because this one
doesn't have any anything stored in it
but he can tell it comma why wouldn't it
shouldn't it default what should it
default to if there are hundreds of
variables no it's it's hard to find what
does that mean okay I owe the Y bracket
one that's an array why oh no a square
bracket one inside the string why
because it's an array and because this
component is an array but how do I know
that
I mean what's Y sub 1 and y sub 2 why is
there always up to that
because the general form of this
component has multiple yeah but it
doesn't but this one doesn't have it I
mean wouldn't in the general form if I
if I said if I made this thing be a
two-dimensional table what would it do I
think that I can the diagram would still
look the same I'm guessing Stevens even
if it has a hundred so it really seems
to me that this diagram should be
improved for this case of data because I
mean clearly when this data the data is
just a parameter that doesn't affect the
diagram
okay but the fact is but the diagram is
a symbolic like this is the kind of so
if I if I do a two dimensional version
of this right so I say just say random
real 10 comma 5 5 it's probably gonna
interpret all of your data as time
values the diagram never changed
the data not great in my opinion I mean
do you really think that's a good idea
to not change the diagram of the data
seems yeah I enough no I mean the
diagram should surely change if it can
with the data but it can't why not
because that's not how diagrams work
what do you mean I mean if you look if
you scroll up to your mechanical thing
you have the top of the screen there the
body doesn't get bigger if you have add
more mass to it no but their parameter
values are given here aren't they
yes viewed as a parameter
but so what are these data values if
they're not parameters of some kind they
are parameters okay so why aren't they
drawn in there somehow
I mean it's given the bails there are
hundreds of them but there aren't in
this case there's one of them in this
case right so I mean in this case right
you are annotating the diagram based on
the actual parameter values yes so you
could perfectly well annotate this
diagram with the little graphic showing
the actual behavior no why not because
it that the annotation features we have
are very limited it's basically telling
you where is that annotation stuff
coming from from them what ethical
standard that's the part of the language
so you can basically orbit them right
out parameter values I mean we are
changing these diagrams because we made
their own icons and things right so we
could make our own icon for this too and
the icon for this could be something
with as parametrize based on the actual
data no why not it it could be something
else but it can't be parameterised on
the data was because the language
doesn't allow you that advanced
parameter ization of the diagram
it's very it's a very simple way to just
get some basic information into the
diagram
I don't understand I mean it just seems
wrong to me but look it's not wish we
have to fry here it just seems wrong
there I mean there is not that much
value in getting some why isn't there
value I mean that that way if you have
three different data tables you can
actually see which one is which
right just like in an interpolating
function sure there is some value right
we do it for interpolating functions we
do it for time series and for a reason
but then we can't do it here I mean it
seems yeah we can't do them here are you
saying we cannot do it here we cannot do
it here because of the way that this is
wired up through Metallica yes okay not
great but I guess that's the way it is
for now
um okay so this really complicated thing
so that this is
I mean there's a lot of detail here I
mean I haven't a clue whether that's all
the stuff this is obviously really
complicated yeah um I mean this is the
most complicated function of all of them
what happens if I say data set does it
have a nice display with data set yeah I
think it's called property data set and
there is also some usually there's a
canonical yeah okay go ahead what were
you gonna say there's a there are three
properties there's a property
Association property data set and
summary
summer is the short one which means what
you basically short over you
hmm okay
so so if I say property data set that's
gonna be some very complicated things
that correct yeah that's gonna explode
especially for this 3d mechanic thing
which has tons of equations which we
don't fully support in and Wolfram
language okay so what would happen if I
asked for the equations
you'd get a huge list of things can I
get some smaller set I mean how many
equations okay it's the two thousand two
hundred and ninety four equations that's
a lot of equations yeah it's a lot of
equations is it is it surprising that
the number of equations this is hardly
the most beautiful I mean if we if
you're gonna have this thing surely you
should have it a bit smaller given that
most of these pie charts are gonna be
pretty boring all right yeah sure I can
make it smaller I don't think it half
the size just because they'll mostly be
dull okay
so what else do we want to make sure to
cover here we're sort of running out of
time but what else do we want to make
sure to cover yeah I mean these were the
main points we hadn't touched on before
in the lot of depth here which I don't
feel as confident with I mean you know
um it's actually very it's very
impressive it's very interesting but we
certainly have not done anything even
close to a full review no no not of
these so what take a quick look at I
can't I I let's see if you go to chat
there's a link you could look at that
one and there's a number two based on
that too so it's just
started single font size and number two
looks at some kind of scaling of fonts
as the string gets bigger this mod -
yeah
I got to 32 where it seemed like it just
you know unless we go to two lines it's
not gonna work beyond that and I think
that's that that doesn't happen that
often yeah yeah well it seems quite
reasonable now what are you gonna do if
they if the core icon is the funky shape
um so we're fixed to the height I think
that's probably a men width I think we
just fit it in that that shape we could
go wider if we had to we had a really
wide aspect ratio we could go wider I
wouldn't go I wouldn't change it beyond
that no we could chop it off if
necessary yeah yeah we could I mean if
it's bordered with white it could be
chopped and we just show the center of
it or we show the left-hand side of it
I'm taking a color for anything that the
model or the component it should drive a
colored border it should be distinct
from the diagrams kind of just graphics
yeah well so so graphics and diagrams
the diagrams and the components they
look similar you know but they're gonna
need some the models and component needs
some active colors because they're you
know there's some data there do things
like they like the graphics is orange
yeah the diagram comes back as the
graphics objects it's just a dead
graphics object just a picture so that
needs to look pretty different than the
model itself
right now a the rounded rectangle and
the color will do a lot of that and you
have the plus sign right I think we
could skip the dot but in the beginning
I think it's be employed
okay okay uh and that will be up maybe a
tooltip other already tooltips on these
things that give the full name yep
there are yes okay that seems pretty
reasonable to me so so then this is the
icon property of system model correct
right no I I con for a system model so
if you go system model Metallica and
then icon okay so okay thumbnail or
something then yeah pretty much what
does that mean this one is an example so
it has like play button like icon hmm
okay so maybe we should qualify that
name icon sorry what well I mean a
prefix is what Steven think yeah I'm not
following
because I got there like icon or
something like that okay right because
what is it I mean it's the icon here
really refers to the notion of icon used
in Metallica but we started to introduce
right we ever we have a really funky
function called icon eyes which doesn't
seem to icon eyes
you know ya Metallica icon make sense I
mean it matches the Metallica display in
Mullica string right but then we should
have a name the thing that we are now
designing should have a name should have
been extractable property of a system
model
yeah the thumbnail fits I think yeah I
think it's fine yep
um okay sounds good alright anything
else that we should go over here now I
mean I would love to see more of this I
mean there's that it looks like boy I
mean you've got a whole system models
open/close thing which what is that
going to give me
that's gonna give you a typeset list of
every single system also that's gonna
take a while to render so in the
documentation when you go to system
model don't you want to point that to
some model library that's on don't we do
we have a model library on the web at
this point we do effectively
don't we in the system modular
documentation
well the documentation for the libraries
are on reference okay but then but then
what I'm suggesting is just like where
we have okay this is probably a bad idea
that just like so to give an analogy
when we have um if you go to for example
import for instance or ya go to import
right we have this thing that says
listing of formats there right
um and we also have things that go well
a pager that one goes to a guide page
but we have other ones which are going
to go to what's a good example um let's
see I think resource data yeah that just
goes there
right and I think that's the right way
to do it for system model I think when
we have a resource data repository with
example models no but don't you say we
have on reference where is where is the
thing on reference right those aren't
actually the reference wolfram welcome
slash system modeler
those aren't actual model stores are
just the documentation for this stuff we
ship with the product we do have on the
real on the Wolfram Whatcom slash system
or however we have nobody near here
sorry I I don't know if it's all
documentation for for the stuff that you
already get with the product then there
is the libraries no no no no no but I'm
making a different point I'm saying if I
go to system model right in the
documentation and I want to know how do
I actually find a model that is a
lightbulb or something right
right by the way we should change that
yes it's going to change in the next
release the the good news here is that
this is a nice piece of documentation so
all you have to do is to point from
system model to something like you know
system model information or something
like this right it has a link like that
so the fighting chance of being able to
go from the system model page to being
able to go to a whatever it is you know
I'm making sense yeah yeah sure that
make sense the whatever all these are
engine v6 that looks cool so so now my
next question is if I get two engine v6
and I click something here can I get
something which I can copy/paste into
here we want when we do a redesign these
pages two more follow the new
documentation style to get the copy
where is the string that I could paste
into here unfortunately it's still only
in the URL
that's a real mess in the design okay
well okay so can you at least make a
workflow that describes how to do that I
mean is is these pages rebuilding those
pages to have a a copy-paste herbal
because the main issue is you know so if
I say system model so I mean this this
is a reasonable workflow if I say system
model quotes and then that horrific URL
wow that was fast how could that be so
fast that's all cached okay it's not
actually downloading anything is this
all stuff we ship ship with the product
okay so if I say system model plot I'm
gonna get some cool engine running this
is pretty cool you're gonna get a cool
plot though some of the variables in the
engine oh I understand but that's right
but that's still very cool I mean this
is yeah yeah yeah that's cool okay but
but the one thing that's missing in this
picture is a is a reasonable way for me
to go to pick up this you know this
actual model so what's the minimal how
close are you to a redesign of these
pages um I'm not sure I haven't been
driving that I think it's at the stage
where we have said we want to do this
and we have good ideas for it it doesn't
happen yet who's working on that I don't
think anyone is actively working on it
what would it take to do the minimal
change to just have a copy-paste of all
you know system model open/close if you
said diagram and you said you know you
have an extra line here that says
Wolfram language form right we can look
into that yeah I don't think that's
unreasonable right and if you use the
the what's the name fangs trick of for
the you know you know what I'm talking
about the yeah the hover a click thing
yes
this is very impressive guys I mean I
assume it's correct and means something
well I mean the fact that I can just go
and pick up some model of a v6 engine
you know from randomly you know going
into the documentation and then
simulated and get something reasonable
here this is amazing yeah if you open it
and simulations under you can actually
get the animation as well we don't have
the 3d animation and in the Wolfram
language yet are we going to at some
point it's off you know to get the right
level of performance in it yeah and by
the way how would I go from here to open
it in the there's a function called
system modeler but you give the model
argument yeah so take that thing that
you have up there you just call system
modeler of percent 46 and this is an
important workflow Steven to go back and
forth this is just sort of a richer
interface it's use more useful for some
things
okay now you're gonna be able to see the
3d animation eventually well the gays
are lovely um now if you click the
animation a little bouncing ball thingy
in the toolbar likes to defy what well
at the top of the window next to the
blue eye there is a little red bouncing
ball button yeah we can press play and
see this either engine running I
probably want to change the time scale
to something different like 0.1 and I
mean if you press the infinity button it
keeps looping
Wow excuse
later than with tracking in the nation
that's cool can I resize the animation
no I just killed it
no I think it's just behind the window
we get to it in the window menu
very cool so but this ultimately in
Wolfram language if we had timed
graphics that would be relevant for
making these things is that true
something like that I mean yeah there
would be like a sequence of 3d graphics
or parametrized 3d graphics but what we
want is Bram we need something yes a
Wolfram language that's like a scene
graph where you can modify you know not
not the the soup expression that we have
now something that's more structural
right you know all right so well very
cool guys um
okay all right we should wrap up here um
and I I guess I mean this is a big
complicated deep area you know we should
mark it as experimental and hope for the
best I guess
I mean I'm not sure that I mean look
we've been using it for 4 5 years you
know users that I understand video it's
not totally clean I mean these things
like how does it save in notebooks and
so on there will be things will you know
write jump in there's there's projects
to come or a curate over the next six
months including cloud including
resource system you know there are
different this workflow listen this this
workflow and just do remember on a bunch
of those pages to put those orange link
things into that web documentation
because that workflow that we just did
is a really wonderful and impressive
work flow right really really quite
wonderful and quite relevant to a lot of
people I mean that because that's the
place to get started I mean people okay
once you know when somebody would also
do this thing you you could pick up in a
different way this is a ready simulate
able model okay there's also system
model examples will also give you a
browsable way to get all of those about
a thousand of them
I met what is system model examples it's
this intro
the browser we looked at last time oh my
gosh I really need to go um yeah I'm not
a big fan of this I'm really not a big
fan I just don't think it should be in
this place I think it's a different
thing I think this is basically
documentation it is in a way I think
it's just this is not the right thing
dynamic if you load more libraries they
will show up great
so should they and documentation I mean
that's that's how our documentation
works as well I mean this is
documentation and it's it's perfectly
nice but you know this should be a piece
of the documentation
I just think this is accessed in the
wrong way I mean this should be part of
help and part of documentation not not a
function I don't think we make instance
you know examples like this
documentation we don't I mean we could
but we don't totally but we don't have
any is different from you know we don't
have application examples let's say you
know you have a symbol that does
something okay
now you have an example like an in you
know a differential equation or
something you know that is not itself
documented that can be referred to and
go to it's just part of that page well I
understand that but that's what we're
trying to do with the repositories and
things like the data repository to the
neural net repository chiz why that will
fit Stephen and we are completely you
know right I mean I think to me the fact
that this this type of thing here which
is quite wonderful by the way
you know is a is a decent fit for
something like this so you could have
searched this one here like let's say
you type engine and that's is you know
search model examples yeah yeah I get it
I get it I mean I'm just saying this you
know I don't why mine we plant you dad
Steven this more of a stopgap measure
maybe we should have that one as
experimental definitely well the whole
thing should be experimental really it
should be I mean nothing it's not gonna
hurt anything to make it experiment no I
agree smite this way we I think it's
safer Steven I agree right but I mean
but this if you can take your already
existing web examples here and make them
into something like this repository this
is gonna be yes yeah then we have it
yeah you know good we're all we've
already agreed to that yeah I understand
okay very very nice okay well I'm just
excited about it okay terrific good
let's wrap up okay all right good you
guys soon okay